oh okay let's try this out so method 2
and us that's gonna carry the
wheelbarrow
[Applause]
[Music]
of course we had to take in our
alternate almost the roller any
gardeners and construction workers would
be impressed by this
[Music]
Oh what would your favorite are on the
net in the car maybe me pay you to hop
in don't you trust me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're gonna turn me into a table tennis
boxer yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
who
[Music]
okay
[Music]
that didn't really work as we thought
very unsuccessful boxing practice the
next challenge is to make a hole in two
records
oh okay it's so frustrating because you
know like the shot would normally go on
[Music]
okay let's make a bigger hole into the
racket yeah there's more whole than
there is right I don't hear to hit the
good size beginner with this it is
actually quite hard
[Music]
that lower part
[Applause]
rather fun to play with this button it's
a cool and last idea here no don't
forget to hit subscribe and what's up
previously there's there until next time